ما عندي مشكله بثلاثه المؤخر يعني خمسه
معقول هلا احنا صح بدنا نضمن حق البنت بس
مش نطير كمان بالارقام بدنا نراعي ظروف
الشباب وانا مع الشباب يعني
يعني انا عن تجربتي عن نفسي اني قبل ثمان
سنوات يعني تزوجت والحمد لله
فاتذكر يعني بوقتها انه من جوده يسالون
ابويا انه شقد تطلب مهر على بنتك وايد حكي
حكايه كلش حلوه قال لهم بنتي فلوس الدنيا
كلها ما تغني اصفر من اظفرها يعني عشره
بعشره هو براحته وبقناعتي بس اني اشوف
المناسبه اشرب عشره
[موسيقى]
التمسوا ولو بخاتم من فضله يعني القصد هو
بالبدايه المهر بصوره اساسيه لغه واصلا هو
يعني معطاء هديه للمراه فيعني ممكن تحديد
قيمه ماديه او معنويا فالمبالغه بالمهر
راح يعيق من الزواج هلا انا بفضي لما اقدم
كتاب قران والمؤخر
ته الانسان بيدفع شو بيدفع ما في مشكله
بقى الناس حسب اوضاعها ما فيك تجبرها باي
شيء
[موسيقى]